Je m'appelle Fatima Massau, je suis
conseillère régionale des Hauts-de-France.
Je suis une retraitée du Crédit Agricole
où j'étais cadre.
C'est mon deuxième mandat
au conseil régional des Hauts-de-France,
et là, je suis vice présidente
à la commission affaires sociales et familiales.
Et je peux dire aussi
que je suis présidente du MoDem de l'Oise.
Je suis arrivée en France il y a 46 ans.
C'est un long long périple,
si je puis dire.
Je suis d'origine marocaine.
Oui, je me suis mariée en 79 et j'ai deux
beaux enfants, une fille et un garçon.
Je suis adhérente à l'UDF d'abord
et au MoDem depuis 37 ans.
Comment je suis arrivée à la politique ?
C'était un hasard.
Mon mari, qui était déjà à l'UDF
à l'époque, pour dire, ce n’est pas simplement,
le MoDem, à l'UDF,
il manquait une femme pour
la parité au Conseil Régional.
Et puis il m'a dit
“Est-ce que ça t'intéresse ?”
Et j'ai dit “pourquoi pas !”
J'ai trouvé en l'UDF une famille,
une très grande famille
humaniste, une famille qui écoute,
une famille en même temps, qui protège
et une famille qui valorise en même temps.
Parce que je me suis sentie vraiment bien
et je me suis dit mais c'est ça le but
recherché, c'est cette famille là.
Et depuis, je ne l'ai pas quittée.
De l'UDF au MoDem jusqu'à maintenant,
et je ne suis pas prête de la quitter.
Comme je l'ai dit,
le MoDem représente pour moi
une vraie famille, une famille humaniste,
une famille qui prend en compte l'humain d'abord.
Et ça,
c'est vraiment très, très important.
Et je pense qu'il y a qu’au MoDem,
qu'on trouve cette sensibilité.